Black Panthers only a few days from
being out and I am so excited to be able
to see it soon for those of you who are
super excited as well and will be seeing
it this weekend
or for those of you if you don't know
much about Black Panther and are going
to see it anyways because it looks like
an awesome movie here's everything you
need to know about Black Panther before
seeing the movie let's first do a very
brief recap on what happened with Black
Panther in Captain America Civil War for
those of you who haven't seen Civil War
yet
spoiler alert Black Panther was first
introduced to us on film in Captain
America Civil War and the beginning
fight scene in Nigeria between Captain
America and crossbones
crossbones in a last attempt to kill
Captain America triggers an explosive V
at attached to him this would have
killed him and Captain America but
Scarlet Witch contained the blast and
shot it up into the sky to save Captain
America's life unfortunately in doing so
she accidentally lets the explosion go
off into a portion of a building and the
explosion kills some people inside the
building and some that were killed were
wakandans enter to Chaka and T'Challa
the Avengers are already split up at
this point after being blamed for the
deaths of the innocent Nigerians and
wakandans some of them such as Iron Man
vision war machine and Black Widow
agreeing to be controlled by a world
power and some not agreeing such as
Captain America Hawkeye ant-man and
Scarlet Witch in an assembly that is
held to chaka who was the current king
of Wakanda is addressing world leaders
about what Condon's and vibranium when
an explosion goes off that kills him
this now makes Prince to chala King the
explosion was blamed on Bucky aka
the Winter Soldier and T'Challa lets
Black Widow note that he's going to find
him and kill him after Captain America
and the authorities find Bucky Bucky
flees but is confronted by Black Panther
and this is the first time that we see
his suit eventually the authorities get
Bucky Captain America and Black Panther
and the fight is stopped
of course they break out and the rest of
the movie is about the war between the
division of the Avengers and about black
panther finding Bucky to kill him at the
end of the movie Black Panther finds out
that it was actually Baron Zemo that
killed his father and not Bucky and he
actually takes Bucky back to Wakanda so
he can go back into stasis for a while
so that's a brief recap of what
happen in civil war let's now talk about
some awesome facts about black panther
himself for starters black panther is
not only the name of the character
created it is also a title that is held
by the king of Wakanda that has to be
earned by going through a series of
trials once earned
T'Challa becomes the king of Wakanda and
the black panther and gets the partake
of the heart-shaped herb which gives him
superhuman abilities such as increased
speed reflexes senses and healing if it
wasn't enough that the heart-shape herb
enhanced his abilities T'Challa was
already a very skilled fighter having
mastered several forms of martial arts
he has mastered several forms of unarmed
combat and being from Wakanda a warrior
race he is also a master of armed combat
enabling him to use many different
weapons on top of being exceptionally
skilled in combat he is a master
strategist as well
he thinks five steps ahead of what he
does he is a brilliant tracker tactician
and planner if all of these weren't
enough to make Black Panther a deadly
force to be reckoned with
he's also a genius T'Challa was educated
by the finest schools in Europe and the
US and has many degrees including
physics to top it all off black panther
suit is one of the most impressive in
the MCU it is made out of vibranium
vibranium is a rare naturally-occurring
meteoric metal with energy manipulating
qualities it is most commonly known for
being what Captain America showed is
made out of so think of the material
that Captain America's shield is made
out of and imagine a suit made out of it
that's what the Black Panther suit is
his suit enables him to withstand
devastating attacks and take bullet
damage with no effect we see several
times in civil war and the trailers for
Black Panther as well as many times when
bullets hit Captain America shield that
bullets don't bounce off vibranium they
just come to a complete stop due to the
vibranium absorbing the kinetic energy
the suit actually has vibranium on the
bottom of the suits boots as well which
create force fields and his soles this
lets T'Challa fall from extremely high
Heights lets him run on water and even
lets him run up walls with enough
momentum he can also use the boots for
attacking and defending the suit can
change its appearance to resemble normal
clothes when he's in public making it to
where he can always wear the suit and to
end it all the suit has energy daggers
that Black Panther can use and the suit
regenerates them allowing him to never
run out as you can see black panther is
packed with a ton of abilities and it's
going to be a super awesome movie to
watch and see how the story unfolds this
is everything you need to know going
into Black Panther it looks like it's
gonna be an amazing movie and it comes
out February 16th let me know if you go
see it and what your thoughts are by
dropping a like and a comment below and
be sure to subscribe to my channel for
everything Black Panther marvel at all
things superhero thank you so much for
watching and have a great day